nature it seems has a thing about
symmetry when we encounter it it makes
us smile when we seek it out we find so
many forms balanced and ordered aligned
and precise we love this
children and adults can lose themselves
staring into the endless shifting
symmetry of the kaleidoscope but why why
do we love a building like this
regardless of its size it's the symmetry
why have centuries of artists equated
beauty with symmetry in ancient Greece
Aristotle wrote the mathematical
sciences particularly exhibit order
symmetry and limitation and these are
the greatest forms of the beautiful
symmetries can be rotational or radial
like a bicycle wheel which looks the
same after we rotate our vantage point
around a single axis reflection symmetry
occurs when two halves of an object are
perfect mirrors like the butterfly one
tip of a symmetrical snowflake tells us
something about all the tips
one petal of the Lotus teaches us about
all the others and one cell of a
honeycomb allows us to understand the
structure of an entire hive with
symmetry as a guide a complex system can
reveal itself be made simpler and easier
for us to understand knowing the
symmetry enables scientists to make
predictions as Einstein did when he
published his theory of general
relativity in 1915 symmetry operates at
many levels young German mathematician
Emmy Noether lived the asymmetry of
being the sole woman in a world of old
men she was a Jew in Nazi occupied
Europe but she found a stunning symmetry
in her equations
she formulated what we now call
no--there's theorem which says that any
symmetry we see in nature as a
corresponding conserved quantity that
symmetrical bicycle wheel for example
keeps its rider upright due to
conservation of angular momentum
experiments confirming the predictions
of Einstein know there and others have
convinced many scientists that symmetry
is at the very heart of our
understanding of the universe they've
proposed an even deeper space time
symmetry called supersymmetry which
describes a world in which each particle
in nature has a super partner or
companion particle at the newly upgraded
CERN supercollider in Switzerland the
race is on to test that theory
symmetry has always entranced our eyes
and minds but is it also a clue to the
deeper order of the universe
you